SCP-035 Vs SCP-049.
An evil mask with frightening supernatural
powers against a plague doctor tragically
cursed with a deadly touch.
But who would win in a battle?
Honestly, this is a tough one.
Whether SCP-049 could kill one of 035’s
hosts with a deadly touch is an open question.
However, it’s possible, if 035’s host
isn’t particularly strong, that a legion
of the Plague Doctor’s zombies may be able
to bum rush it.
The real question, and the one we’re having
trouble with, is whether SCP-035 could trap
049 and convert him into another host.
It all depends on the pliability of the mask:
Because if the mask is rigid, there’s a
good chance that 049’s unusual face shape
would save his life, and bag him the victory
over 035.